you can still have community in a
virtual world right you don't have to
only have Community because people walk
into a building with four walls every
day you can be very intentional in fact
the more intentional you are you can
absolutely create community on a global
scale it's just about making the time
and being thoughtful about it and being
deliberate about hey you know what I'm
going to give Michael a call today and
we're going to spend five or ten minutes
just catching up on what happened over
the weekend right you can integrate it
into what you do as you kick off your
meetings as opposed to making your
meetings all about tasks and kind of you
know project updates you can also weave
in that that personal element as well
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by J Ventures a
Community Driven VC Fund in celkon
Valley in partnership with luamitec
sponsored by Homeward Ventures hippo
Insurance Opera slabs Synergy Global
hello at Stanford leap Birthright Excel
Serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Shara Roman the author of The
conscious workplace and the founder and
CEO of the silverine group a culture
consulting firm that is on a mission to
help build better more inclusive
workplaces previously she held
leadership positions in Fortune 500
companies born in India schooled in
Nigeria and England and having lived in
Greece before coming to the U.S Shara
uses their Global Experience as the
foundation for crafting strategies to
improve culture Workforce quality and
operations across a multitude of
disciplines in the public private and
non-profit sectors Shara also serves on
several advisory and non-profit boards
she's a charismatic speaker and an
adjunct professor at Georgetown
University
Shara Roman welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you I'm well thanks Michael
thanks so much for having me here it's
uh great to have this chat with you
today I'm looking forward to it
thank you very very much for taking time
to be here and recently author of The
conscious workplace founder and CEO of
the silver Reno group and you know your
background is so fascinating even before
we start talking about what does it even
mean the conscious workplace or the
silverine group I'd love for you to tell
me a little bit about your upbringing
and sort of the way that you maneuvered
around the world and how that helped
shape a little bit about how you're
thinking through leadership and
workplace yeah great thank you so much
um so I was born in Bombay India and at
a very young age I was around two we
moved my parents moved tonight Lagos
Nigeria and I did my elementary school
years there went back to uh back to
India for a couple of years then went to
England and did my high school there
um went back to Nigeria where my parents
had been living and ended up living for
25 years met my husband who is a
Puerto Rican from New York who was at
Community Marine Corps at the time
stationed at the American Embassy wow
and uh we met moved to Grace uh where he
was his on his second Duty station ended
up getting wow and then coming to the
U.S yes like that's a whole exhausting
um sort of upbringing but what that did
you know for me is I was a guest in
someone else's country for a really
large part of my life and what that
meant is that I had to figure out how to
to sort of you know fit in but to also
still be who I was
um because I was really raised by
um you know my sort of the family values
of like don't sell yourself short don't
sell out who you are you know be true to
yourself and kind of what you believe in
and as you're trying to make friends and
as you're trying to like fit in
um you know fitting in sometimes means
giving up all of those personal
identifications right
um and I didn't want to do that and so
that had a lot to do with just how I
approach
kind of making friends how I approached
living in different countries
recognizing and respecting that you know
you are
um living somewhere else so you have to
learn about what's going on there but
also to to be open and share about my
own life experiences right and how those
have shaped the person I am today
wow
was there a specific part of this
journey that LED you thinking about
leadership and the workplace in a more
um coherent and strategic way what was
the trigger for these types of for this
type of thinking
yeah you know that's a that's a really
really good question I
um
I think it was a combination of
everything I as I sort of really
reflected
um you know probably over the last five
ten years
um well probably
more like 10 years before I started my
business
um
I reflected on sort of what was
important to me or what what were some
of those key moments as a as a child and
as a young adult and then as I
came into the workforce here I would say
that the the biggest piece was there was
always
um you know there was I was very lucky
to have good leaders people who were
authentic people who really cared about
me people who were vested in my interest
or in my development you know invested
in in me getting to know me interested
in getting to know me
um and recognizing that I wasn't just
sort of
um you know some stereotype no
uh it and when I think back to you know
my time in school in England or my time
in India where I actually felt probably
the most uncomfortable and the most like
a fish out of water there was someone
you know always sort of playing that
role of of coach and died and asking
questions and
um helping me to navigate you know
whatever might have been going on for me
so I don't know that it was a particular
moment but it was people in those
leadership roles whether they were
traditional leadership roles or just
leadership roles as
you know a a a prefect in a in a school
and and people and sort of they that you
know England and and sort of the the
more British types will will know what I
mean by by a prefect we don't tend to
have those here in the United States
[Music]
I don't think that we anybody needs
introduction as to why culture and
workplace is important I think also the
last few years have been um
very uh the market education that
probably your your line of work has
received over the last few years was
very very interesting tell me a little
bit from your perspective
work the the cultural shifts that we've
seen the different mindsets around the
world
um that we've observed over the last few
years leading up to what we understand
today about culture and workplace
because it feels at least from
a young Engineers an entrepreneur's
perspective that there has been a pretty
significant shift in the eyes of a lot
of different stakeholders in the supply
chain of of tech and business in general
over the last few years
yeah for sure there's been a shift
unfortunately I don't know the shift has
been as as deep and as pervasive as we
would like but the good news is that
people are starting to pay attention to
the fact that that culture is uh what is
going to make or break your your company
and uh I think there are a couple of
things that have really sort of driven
that one is our
um the generational of the demographic
shifts that have occurred where you've
got the Gen Z's uh you know those born
um those that are like sort of in their
early 20s and and younger that have
started to graduate from college and
come into the workforce but even before
coming into the workforce in their
school lives they are
um you know highly active they are
digital natives uh you know they're
incredibly resourceful and realistic and
authentic
uh they're not deferential to Authority
right if they see a problem they kind of
go after it so you've had that shift in
terms of what's happening with the
generation
and coupled with the 70 80 million of
them in the U.S plus the the Millennials
that are also 70 80 million that is a
huge sort of force that is pushing
companies to behave in a different way
but secondly quite honestly the pandemic
I think had a huge shift on how how
companies have had to
um reshape
their value proposition to employees and
how they sort of have to think about
culture in a much more intentional way
um you know with the pandemic right
we've seen
increased levels of burnout and
increased levels of stress and the fact
that people are really driving
um kind of the talent shortage right
because people are not just taking jobs
to take a job they're actually realizing
um that they have a choice and that they
want to
that they are going to exercise that
choice and that ability to decide who
they want to work for where they want to
work for how they want to work so I
think those two big confluences have
really shifted the conversation
now do you feel that the because a lot
of people have been talking about you
know the burnout and stress and leading
to to a lot of different cultural shifts
was that because people were working
longer hours or harder than covet or was
covered in the shifts that it brought
with it sort of opened the eyes of
people and that all of a sudden we're
asking themselves questions that they
weren't asking themselves before I think
it's both right I think we were we were
are slash are working harder and longer
than we did before so all of this talk
about you know productivity being up
during covid
it's up because everyone's working
probably 20 30 percent more than they
were before the lines between life and
work have blurred completely right and
you know if you're working from home
it's like not everyone has a dedicated
office so their office is you know a
corner of their dining table or kitchen
table so it's very hard to sort of
switch off and put those boundaries on
so that has contributed
um you know to to the burnout and then I
think the
um uh not I think but you know what I
what I've read and what I've seen and
what I believe is that
because we experienced such
uh such a life-changing event in the
pandemic we experience loss
um we experienced you know grief and we
experienced it all collectively
um across the globe right we've not
really had anything like that in any of
our lifetimes and that has caused people
to say why am I selling my soul to some
company that at the bottom line nobody
really cares about me right like why are
we doing this and why do I have to buy
into this oh you've got to keep hustling
your way up you know to the coroner
office to the uh reserved parking space
to whatever kind of ridiculous perks
that uh people were chasing in the past
when they realized that time with family
with friends with kind of just having a
good life is what
um a healthy life right is what
ultimately is is more important
I love that so tell me a little bit
about the conscious workplace the book
yeah so
um it just came out a couple of weeks
ago and it's a it's a it's a book
written for for managers for leaders
um but really accessible to to everybody
the point of the book is to really get
us in a conversation that I think we
need to have more of which is around you
know put your people put purpose put
passion before profits and profits will
come so let's think about our businesses
with you know with the triple bottom
line as opposed to a single bottom line
don't let's have the numbers purely
drive the conversation there are a ton
of uh success stories out there of
companies that um that do put purpose
and people ahead of profits and
um you know let's just rethink that that
conversation in a in a really uh and
have a meaningful positive dialogue
around it so I'm I'm super excited to to
have it I know this is this is a podcast
but it's it's great to to hold the book
to feel the book to to talk about it and
hear hear what others think about it as
well
so I'd love for you to share some
insights from the book on different ways
that we can be proactive in in you know
given that we understand the importance
of
of the messages here what what are some
things that you know young entrepreneurs
Tech leaders Business Leaders can do to
to Really take a step forward in the
right direction with with everything
that we just talked about yeah so I
think first of all is is really kind of
getting in the right mindset right that
we have to recognize and as you all are
you know young entrepreneurs coming into
the workforce
um or kind of leading different
organizations you don't have to
necessarily follow the blueprint that
was there before
um that is about sort of hierarchy and
control and
um sort of super uh you know sort of
super structured and non-collaborative
workplaces you can really create a new
paradigm and you can really recognize
that the workforce that we have today
that comprises of of women of people of
color people with varying disabilities
and abilities
and you know people from all walks of
life that we have huge Talent potential
at our disposal
so think about things sort of
differently and think about it
differently from the context of
inclusion and then as you as you think
about your organizations and as you're
building a company you know be conscious
of what is the kind of culture that you
want to have because
as you start it may not really be that
big of a deal or it might just be a
handful of people in a room but as you
continue to grow
um you will get a culture whether you
are intentional about it or not so you
probably want to be con be conscious
about it be intentional think about your
values think about how those are going
to come to life
um how are you going to really Drive
purpose and connect people back to to
what you do
uh you know second create a sense of
community in your organization
Community is super important for us we
want to have friends at work we want to
feel that we're connected to um you know
a greater good we want to feel that
we're working with people that um that
are also kind of you know moving with us
and kind of rowing that boat in the same
direction so create that sense of
um create that sense of community
third I would say think about your
talent about nurturing and cultivating
your talent at the end of the day you
know we are knowledge workers and what
we have is is in our brains and is sort
of walking out the door so to speak
whether it's the
um uh kind of the actual door if you
have a physical office or the virtual
door right if you're if you're virtual
um but you really want to think about
how are you going to cultivate your how
are you going to nurture your talent and
help grow them and help really get to
know people
um while they might be helping Advance
your business they're also human beings
and you're going to get more out of the
people
um and end up being more successful as a
company if you are really committed to
you know growing and developing the the
talent that's on your on your team
and finally I would say
um really Foster that ownership
mentality so ownership can come in a
couple of different ways it can come in
terms of owning a piece of the company
whether it's through Equity or you know
a profit sharing model or uh in an
employee stock ownership plan whatever
that might look like but you can also
create ownership through empowering
people to make decisions through
um you know including their ideas and
perspectives as you develop the strategy
um where you can really lean into a
coaching mindset versus a directing and
a telling mindset uh where you're
democratizing decisions and being
transparent all of those things uh
create that sense of ownership where
people feel they are fully bought into
what you're doing and they feel that
they can influence the future direction
of your organization and as a young
entrepreneur you want everybody on your
on your team right you want them all
rooting for you and helping you succeed
100 yeah I think one of the things that
that I've been thinking about a lot as
I'm as I'm examining different
organizations as an angel investor or BC
whatever and and getting to think about
you know what are the different things
that work and don't work for creating a
sense of community for creating the
culture that you want
um and being intentional about it
creating that sense of ownership it
feels like a lot of times
or at least for some part of the last
couple years we a lot of entrepreneurs
understood the importance of culture and
spoke a lot about it but in fact when it
came down to the details
the there they weren't acting any
differently than the example that they
learned how not to act yeah and um and
that's why I think and then you know the
devil's in the details and it and and
I'm going back to what you said about
eight minutes ago about that it's that
it starts with a mindset and it's not
necessarily one single thing that that
you do but it sounds to me like what
you're describing here is sort of a
whole more holistic approach to how how
am I thinking about the people that I'm
working with
in the this idea of getting ownership
this is not a single action that I'm
doing I'm not literally giving them
ownership but I have to constantly
I constantly
um behave with them where I'm giving
them ownership right it's in every
single interaction it's not in one in
one immediate action right yes and
that's a really great I'm glad you kind
of framed it in that way because often
we you know people want our people come
to us sort of asking for like a
checklist or sort of a right right like
I want this to be sort of done you know
by the end of next month it's like it's
sort of a journey you know you can use
it as a weight loss Journey or or a
helpful Health Journey right like you
know just because you eat the apple
today does that does not make you any
healthier than you were yesterday but
it's about a lifestyle change it's about
thinking about how you're going to to do
things in a much more holistic uh
holistic way and it's also not about uh
Michael it's not about copying what
other people are doing either right
because that's the other kind of quick
fix oh well you know Google has been so
successful this way so I'm just going to
do what they do well sure sure not it
were
um yeah and and I do want to underscore
one piece that you mentioned about
Community
um that I probably forgot to mention
earlier is that you can still have
community in a virtual world right you
don't have to only have Community
because people walk into a building with
four walls every day you can be very
intentional in fact the more intentional
you are you can absolutely create
community on a global scale it's just
about making the time and being
thoughtful about it and being deliberate
about hey you know what I'm going to
give Michael a call today and we're
going to spend five or ten minutes just
catching up on what happened over the
weekend right you can integrate it into
what you do as you kick off your
meetings as opposed to making your
meetings all about tasks and kind of you
know project updates you can also weave
in that that personal element as well
100 100 hey sure I have one Nick last
question it's the million dollar
question here why do you do what do you
do
well I want to
um help build better workplaces right at
the end of the day
um 85 of our Workforce is uh globally is
disengaged which means they're they're
not jumping out of their their bed every
morning to go to work and if there's
something I can do uh by working with
with the companies that we do and and
new ones and uh more organizations to to
build better workplaces where people can
be their full selves where they can feel
included where they can be creative
where they can innovate
we're going to help not just those
individuals and the organizations but
we're going to have a much broader
impact on the communities we live in as
well and that's what charges me up
incredible
I love it Shara thank you so much this
was so enjoyable hey wishing you best of
luck with uh with the recent launch of
the book and with the rest of your
um with the rest of the impact that
you're making on organizations it's such
an interesting topic that thank you
Michael it's been really fun chatting
with you so thanks so much
yeah I really appreciate it and stay
safe and say help thank you yeah you too